the seahawks and the 49ers are going to
rough each other up on sunday night
that's the culmination of the 2019
season game number 256
the game with the most incredible most
dramatic most significant potential
swings and for the 49ers it's as big of
a swing as it can get chris because if
they win they're the one seed period no
matter what happens earlier in the day
beat the seahawks in seattle 49ers of
the one seed lose
and they're the five seed going on the
road to face the cowboys or the eagles
in the first round of the playoffs next
weekend both these teams really need a
bye week for the seahawks depending upon
what happens earlier in the day they're
gonna be playing for the three seed
versus the five seed the two seed versus
the five seed or the one seed versus the
five seed now i don't know that it's
realistic for the seahawks to have the
one seed up for grabs they would need
the packers to lose to the lions and the
saints to lose to the panthers i think
the way it's gonna play out is the
seahawks are gonna be playing for the
three seed versus the five seed which
means they would host the vikings in the
wild card round that is what i think is
ultimately going to happen but but if
they win
if the 49ers win though they're the one
seed and the seahawks end up uh on the
road playing the cowboys or the eagles
either way a lot is hanging in the
balance for this prime time game in
seattle
and i'm having a hard time i i did my
official pft picks yesterday we're doing
our pix podcast later today i reserve
the right to change my pick from
yesterday on any of the games okay and
i'm really thinking about changing my
pick on that one because it felt good
about 49ers yesterday the more i think
about it man it's seattle it's prime
time they have some ridiculous record
under pete carroll like they never lose
at home
at night they never do how can we ignore
that going into this night game against
the 49ers well no i i hear that you're
right i mean they're they're a special
team at home uh at night in prime time
but not that special at home this year i
think that's the first thing we need to
talk about i mean yeah you know the the
seattle 12 the home field advantage has
not been as great this year definitely
not plus the seahawks are reeling a
little bit you know they really are i
mean hey giudevian clowney he hasn't
been out there for a defense that's in
strugglesville you know offensively you
talk about dwayne brown all the running
backs all those things i'm concerned
about the seattle seahawks there's no
other way to say it with the injuries
they've had you know what quandary digs
back banged up in the at the safety
position but just the injuries they've
had to a defense that's not all that
great to begin with and then on offense
mike that you hear me talk about a lot i
mean their game is about overpowering
people up front oh now we're playing
man-to-man and russell wilson's going to
hit you deep but they're not the type of
offense that's going to just surgically
dissect you in the past game boom boom
boom boom boom that way when the run
game's not working that's not what
they're made to do their offensive
schematics in the passing game are not
like special creative that way so i am
concerned and i think to your home field
point mike like seattle maybe other than
green bay and the nfc is a team i look
at that
needs home field advantage or the bye
week maybe just as much or needs it more
than anybody else in the nfc to get to
the super bowl i guess is my main point
there
yeah and i look i i as i said earlier i
think both these teams desperately need
a week off the 49ers had their buy in
week four the seahawks are a work in
progress now dealing with all these
injuries they've got marshawn lynch and
robert turbin back on the team you know
i was joking on sunday night about
marshawn lynch returning to the seahawks
but there weren't a lot of options out
there at running back and as it turns
out lynch was kind of plotting this
potential return and it all worked out
perfectly for him not perfectly for
chris carson or cj process because
they're both on injured reserve now
along with rashad penny but they needed
the help and they have lynch back and
chris i and your guy kyle shanahan
talked about this earlier in the week
about how hard it will be for lynch and
turbo to make an impact right away
they're not in football shape no they
got fresh legs right right so that'll
help them in a week or two or three if
the seahawks are still alive but it's
going to be very hard for them to make
an impact right away when they're just
not in football shape yeah no exactly
you know and to those out there going
you know what the hell is that well yeah
they got fresh legs like mike said so
when you know those first few carries of
a game they're going to come out looking
you know just explosive as can be but
it's you know
it's plays 8 through 12 8 through 15 you
know carries 5 through 10 when you're
running through the line of scrimmage
and you're just going all out you know
pedal to the metal dragging people
hitting people you know anxiety and
adrenaline flowing at it that is utmost
those that's what football shape is and
that's like it's impossible to replicate
that intensity and that emotion let
alone the physical output you're putting
when yeah deforest buckner's about to
hit you richard sherman's about to hit
you oh now i need to outrun jaquasky
tart to the sideline that's football
shape and there's nothing you can do
there you know i i expect marshawn lunch
it sounds like he's in pretty good shape
to be a contributor but can he rip off
big plays and make game-changing plays
at the running back position that's one
where i like i gotta see it to believe
it
yeah i agree with you and i think the
longer that they last in the post season
the greater the potential impact
marshawn lynch will have and and who
knows you know some people view him as a
fringe hall of famer i think he should
get in based upon what he's already done
but he could do enough over the course
of january to really put some icing on
top of the cake to get himself in if he
can have an impact when we get to wild
card round divisional round championship
round who knows they may not play in the
wild card round at all it all comes down
to whether or not they win on sunday and
whether or not they get the help they
need in the form of the lions beating
the packers and or the panthers beating
the saints consider some of these
historical facts though chris yeah as it
relates to the 49er seahawks rivalry in
seattle right
the 49ers are one and nine in seattle
this decade their only win came against
tavares jackson in 2011.
that's it they have not won in seattle
the rest of the time they've played
there this decade including playoffs and
they've never scored
20 or more points in seattle during the
pete carroll era that is scary and i
know that that's all the past and it can
all be different now and this is a
better offense than the 49ers have
arguably ever had during their time
right over the past decade but it it's
the kind of thing that gets me a little
nervous about my my prior belief in the
49ers winning the game yeah well i i get
it i mean
mystique is there is something to that
to a degree
you know of course those stats are the
way they are because seattle had a you
know an almost dynasty in the first half
of this decade of course and a defense
that was you know rewriting the record
books and doing special things that way
with the legion of boom but i do think
this is a different san francisco 49ers
team uh as far as any that they've seen
here in recent recent history i mean the
explosiveness on the offensive side of
the ball is pretty top-notch shanahan
has great comfort level with pete
carroll i feel like again i i'm i'm
already saying that i'm picking the
49ers to win this football game i got a
seattle with seattle all the injuries
and i understand the 49ers got injuries
on defense too and they're reeling but
with seattle and all the injuries the
way they've played as of late which is
losing two of three and really not
looking impressive in two out of those
three um
and added to the fact on
i don't think it's realistic the way
they won game one which was the deviant
clowney f up the play extravaganza i
mean that's what it was you know if you
go back and look at the fourth look at
the look at the team stats for four
quarters the seahawks were around 230
total yards their touchdown drives were
24 yards 16 yards things like that i
don't know if it's realistic for them to
win that type of game again against the
san francisco 49ers i guess that's my
big question mike
and as you mentioned the seahawks aren't
nearly as good this home as at home this
year as they've been in the past four
and three at home and seven and one on
the road embarrassed on sunday against
the cardinals and and you know that you
could look at that and say well it makes
it even more likely they'll find a way
to win this one because you can't
imagine them winning
or losing excuse me two games in a row
at home but they should have lost to the
rams earlier this year they've had that
horseshoe up their butt as you like to
call it yeah on so many different
occasions this year it's almost like it
just had to run out at some point like
with the steelers you know how many
games can you continue to win when
you're not the better team but you just
have all these other things that happen
your way you can't make a living you
can't make it to the playoffs you can't
make it to the top of the mountain with
just everything lining up your way and
allowing you to escape with a victory
you can't you can't sustain that no and
i think we've seen it with the steelers
and we're seeing with the seahawks they
can't sustain it although they are one
of the best teams in the nfc there's a
gap between them and the 49ers and games
that they they
won some of the games they won they
should have lost but you can't look at
any of the games they lost and say they
should have won no you're you're right
and you know they're not made for home
football right now you know what what
makes home like a home field advantage
uh great crowd noise great defense and
seattle yeah that's great crowd noise
but the defense is not good it's towards
the bottom of football pass defense is
really not good and they're one of the
worst sack teams in all of football so
you know that's what a crowd noise is
supposed to do right is help the front
four the defensive line get off the ball
just a split second before the offensive
line does because they can't hear the
snap counter they're trying to look at
the ball whatever that may be those are
one of the things that seattle seahawks
don't have this year they're built a
little bit more around their offense
they're trying to kind of rebuild this
defense that's why they signed ezekiel
anza and jedevian county but they've
been hurt and banged up so they've never
really got to like go through a stretch
of games of going okay we're totally 100
we can start taking it over we never got
to that point with seattle this year and
that's why we've seen them carved up at
home a bunch of times too i mean even in
your vikings game it wasn't a great
showing right you know you think about
that game the monday night football game
a lot of big plays kirk cousins and the
vikings made against that defense it's
just not the same defense we've grown
accustomed to seeing in seattle
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports